on les appelle les jardiniers de la nuit
ces hommes comme angèle moioli font
pousser les champignons de paris sous
terre aujourd'hui seulement 3
champignonnistes exercent dans les
yvelines un métier en perdition nom a
hérité en génois you lie moi je suis
dans l'échantillon une ma famille mon
grand-père était championne is mais pas
en championnat nice donc c'est vrai
chien dangereux mais on sait toujours où
les âmes maison voici toute la famille
un savoir transmis de génération en
génération qu'angel moioli souhaite
partager avec le public lors des
journées du patrimoine c'est le
patrimoine de la région parisienne
champions ou de paris comme monde et
champions de paris cède près de
ferrières paris c'est ici la région ile
de france c'est le début du champion
c'est ici angèle moioli informe mais
souhaite également sensibiliser le
public à la production du champignon
menacé depuis plusieurs années par les
cultures en serre intensive dans les
pays de l'est
si ange elle produisait jadis 900 kg de
champignons de paris par semaine
il se réduit à présent à trois cents 300
kilos qu'il ramasse seul car à montesson
notre jardinier de la nuit s'occupe de
tout après une fois le fumé pasteurisé
on en semences mais le mycélium
normalement un fumier tout noir qu'elle
est pasteurisé la ituri
on va t'oublier a tout plein de petits
filaments c'est tout mais c'est les
hommes qui avaient colonisé le fumier
après quinze jours d'incubation les
filaments sorte à la surface et les
champignons commence à se former pour un
mac de culture normalement on aurait
récolté 50 kg de champignons mais sur
quatre semaine de récolte pour le
cueillir le champion all pro c'est
l'habitude et on tourne on tourne en eau
cas ces filaments et en tire ça craque
et voilà parmi les champignons cultivés
par angèle moioli des champignons de
paris blond et blanc mais aussi des
shiitakés et des pleurotes alpes où ce
sont des blocs de paille mon la paille
hachée pasteurisé
mais c'est l'homme s'est développée dans
le sac en plastique
il ya des troubles ont été faits par une
machine quazar été ensemencés on met la
lumière ça pousse appris à maturité en
accueillir et après une semaine quinze
jours après ressort des filaments que le
pari et se reforme et l'autre pleurotes
et là on va accueillir pendant un mois
ou deux mois
quant au shit ac est venu d'asie il
évolue sur un mélange de paille et de
sueur de bois sans oublier la lumière
pour tout savoir sur la champignonnière
de montesson angèle moioli recevra le
public lors des journées du patrimoine
samedi 15 septembre de 15h à 17h puis
les 20 et 21 octobre pendant la semaine
du goût et pour les gourmands le
champignonnistes vend sa production tous
les jours de la semaine